so you guys may notice something's a
little bit different with this episode
we're in a yacht in Croatia hosted by
Inez and it rents for 150 000 a week and
we got it for completely free they were
so gracious to let us stay on this yacht
it is an absolutely incredible
experience very cool Intro by the way
we're going to be walking all the way up
to the top deck to be shooting a podcast
with NS himself it's going to be an
amazing episode I mean we've never done
anything like this before on the iced
coffee hour so make sure to subscribe
and hit the like button would mean a lot
to us and now let's go see Ennis
before we go into that if you're a
business owner I'm sure you know that
managing a bunch of different systems
spreadsheets and softwares can be a
massive headache so wouldn't it make
sense to have one software instead of 10
that covers all of the back end of your
business well that software exists and
it's called netsuite by Oracle our
sponsor netsuite helps with CRM resource
planning and more they bring everything
your business needs in real time all in
one place a software like netsuite
provides the visibility and control you
need to make better decisions faster
plus over 36 000 companies have already
upgraded to netsuite and stopped wasting
time on things like manual entries and
sifting through scattered data they also
help manage your finances e-commerce HR
inventory and more and for the first
time ever you can defer payments for a
full netsuite implementation for six
months that means no payments no
interest for half a year so whether
you're a small business owner or an
entrepreneur don't miss out on this deal
head over to netsuite.com iced to take
advantage of the special financing offer
today again that's netsuite.com iced as
an iced stay efficient and take your
business to the next level with netsuite
again netsuite.com
iced and now with that said let's get to
the podcast thank you so much for having
us here it has been probably the most
definitely the most luxurious experience
I've ever had in my entire life oh by
far I love it yeah our first European
Vacation first yacht first a lot of
things first podcast abroad yeah pretty
cool fantastic well I'm really glad to
see you guys here I'm really glad that
you guys took this opportunity I figured
you guys would enjoy it but I was kind
of 50 50. I was like maybe they would
find a little too much to travel to
Croatia
and then uh stay on board for seven days
but I'm really happy to see you guys
here easy to sell forever
from you to Graham and I and it was like
would you guys like to join us on this
experience I mean I was just like yes
without question so
and here we go we got some what is this
a
cappuccino's having espressos and then
uh I think Graham's having nice Coffee
iced coffee and the cheese that's right
that's right this is the attention to
detail that they have they know you like
six to seven of these per day by the way
that's absolutely too much we gotta
insane when you're in Europe you gotta
have espressos and Life's good around
here it's like oh selling uh Jack the
other day it's like simple things in
life a simple way of living in Europe is
like what draws me it's like you don't
need to have a crazy coffee with just
milk and frothing it's a good old
espresso amazing views simple way of
living is what I enjoy in Europe yeah
people seem way more relaxed here I've
noticed that maybe it's just like the
touristy locations that we're going to
but you don't have as high as income tax
maybe I'm just kidding that's that's got
to be it's like it's zero percent it's
like us yeah the United States is an
incredible country but it's always go go
you always have to make money if you got
your next paycheck lifestyle here is a
little bit more laid back and even like
all the way down to talking to the
captain yesterday I'm sure you kind of
gotten that feeling a little bit it's
just kind of like uh we were trying to
ask him on his finances and he was like
yeah just I want to make sure everybody
enjoys it and it's like we make money
like that was his answer so I enjoyed
that about Europe and uh I think it's a
nice balance that
myself and our team gets to experience
this but at the same time we go back to
us and we know that Competitive Edge it
kind of gives us a well-rounded
perspective no matter where we go so I
got to know Ennis how do you get access
to a 120 000 a week yacht in Croatia for
completely free well a lot of factors
play into that and for them they want to
Market their asset they want to showcase
how cool crochet is how hospitable they
are with their crew and my pitch to them
was give us the odds for a week I know
it's a bit of an investment on your end
but that will allow us to do really
engaging content that will allow us to
showcase
what it's like to really be on board and
like truly get a vacation experience and
at the same time because this yacht
comes with 14 cabins we got plenty of
space invite friends invite friends that
can add up to our video while they
create their own content and once we
started formulating it from that
perspective you guys got involved Shelby
got involved and here we are but on a
fundamental basis it's all about
creating win-win situations it's all
about understanding the people on the
other side and Bridging the Gap between
what you can do what they like and
finding a nice harmonious mix in the
center and so do you apply this to every
single one of your house tours one by
one case by case every single asset we
should has a different term has a
different catch hook timeline it's all
about you know there are Yachts that we
Tour all they want is their yacht to be
seen they don't care about the charter
experience they're trying to sell it for
them as long as we come into it we put a
suit on we make a nice poly let's walk
through the video that's good enough for
them here it's all about the experience
here is what you guys are experiencing
right now the fact that you wake up in
the morning you go for a swim you get on
a jet board later in the afternoon you
have amazing meals and like you guys
seen every day they're like what time
you want to have lunch what time what
time you want to have dinner so it's a
very curated experience so just touring
this yacht wouldn't do justice to the
whole experience that's why it was a
better call to say let's stay on it and
let's give everybody 100 Access got it
it's interesting you were explaining to
me yesterday that you've positioned
yourself fantastically I mean you
basically have all of these super
massive luxury companies reaching out to
you on a consistent basis asking will
you come experience this lovely vacation
here in Croatia on a yacht so you can
make content market for the company and
it's a win-win on both ends I mean it's
absolutely amazing you've positioned
yourself incredibly thank you thank you
and it's like we created this business
model that is super cool in my opinion
gives access to people without putting
the burden on them like imagine people
that are in their houses right now
watching content most people will never
have access to the level that we do and
I love the fact that we can produce a
video that's cinematic high quality
extensive in detail and allowing people
to experience it for absolutely free so
for those that aren't familiar could you
discuss how you got started doing all
this where did the idea come from long
story short I used to live in Texas I
used to develop properties so I built a
Love For Real Estate over a long period
of time I've invested in a lot of
properties then I always wanted to move
to LA I moved to LA and then that's
where Mikey comes in I knew Mikey back
then from Texas and he was always into
photography videography and when I
became agent in La I was like well
it would be cool to make some content as
you know super competitive to be able to
differentiate yourself as a real estate
agent in Los Angeles is so difficult so
I called Michael I was like why don't
you come live with me uh on this side
we'll make some content we'll start a
YouTube channel together it was really
based on me building a real estate
career or like a name so to speak and as
we started making the videos both of us
saw the potential and kind of the light
uh in regards to how big this can be and
both of us were Keen to improve whatever
we do at the time so we were like look
let's try to get better houses let's try
to spend a couple more hours let's try
to make better videos in general and one
thing led to another and the competitive
Spirit ambitious Spirit just built it up
one step over another and I think we
were very
I don't want to say careful but we were
very articulate about how we use each
opportunity to just barely open the next
door so we always aim for a little bit
more than we can choose so to speak and
if we got a four million dollar house we
always knew okay now we got to get to an
eight million dollar house 10 million
dollar house and one thing led to
another team expanded
our goals grew uh I've totally ditched
my real estate career because I was so
keen on this and quite frankly I enjoyed
it more than real estate too uh you know
sales side of it and um here we are like
it all happened in the last four years
give or take and um I look back and I'm
like wow the four years were just so
dense we we shot 250 Plus Homes we've
traveled so many different countries
but in a weird way it also feels like it
was just yesterday yeah I got to know
how do you guys you guys to the next
level from here because I look at your
recent content and it's like touring the
most expensive Penthouse to ever exist
and you're touring stuff like that or
touring the most expensive RV touring
the most expensive yacht it's like where
do you take it to the next level you
can't get more expensive than the most
expensive that's a great question and
this challenges us as a team all the
time right uh YouTube really benefits
the title most biggest whatever that is
um but to me
narrative is so important to me how you
tell the story is really when you can
differentiate yourself I mean
I use this weird analogy but like look
at David dobrik
he built this massive following and he
built the people around them to such
high level with a camera and sometimes
without even a shotgun mic it's all
about the story it's all about how you
put together a video that engages with
people so obviously we've gone access to
incredible properties and we will go
forward
but now we're focusing on making less
videos and really going a little bit
more in depth you know talking with the
owner trying to understand the story a
lot of times we end up asking for few
Day Access just because we're like look
as a team we want to come we want to
walk the grounds we want to see how this
place feels and I think we're at a point
now
and the type of assets we feature calls
for that really and um I think this is
where we're going to start making videos
where we can look back and say you know
what I don't think anybody is ever going
to produce a video like this I don't
think anybody is going to get access to
Michael Jordan's home spent two days
there right voiceovers get footage from
MBA and put together a video that's like
a legacy video that's one of the reasons
why I to some aspects
differentiate our or like separate our
business from YouTube a little bit and
not be in the mercy of like did we get
20 million views this month you know I
want that to not matter as much I want
to be able to look at our team and say
you know what how do we create the best
video possible that still makes
Financial sense let's go do that let's
be proud of our work and then we'll
figure out the rest so walk us through
the Michael Jordan deal it took us a
little more than a year and a half to
get access to that property initially
when we reached out they didn't want to
do it it's owned by Michael Jordan and
they're always worried about how the
property showcased but long story short
email after email email after email
finally they give us an opportunity to
talk and after a long process of
approvals and permits and like
um access we got uh we got to the
property I believe like six or seven
months ago we shot the video we didn't
tell anyone we took about two months to
edit it and we released it and it's one
of our best videos ever and personally
it was Unreal the fact that we got a
chance to tour Michael Jordan's property
how do you get the contact to begin with
on that um I worked my way through the
agent it was initially kind of a tough
one for us to get access but then
Compass was The Brokerage uh for the
listing and I've talked to the pr team
of compass I was like you guys know us
Compass kind of backed me up they were
like look you really have to consider
this guy on his team like they're really
good they're really professional they'll
work with your terms after that they
really considered us seriously and it
was basically they were like look you'll
come and shoot the video you'll do the
video once it's complete you need to
send us a draft this person needs to
approve this person needs to approve
this person needs to approve and at the
end Michael Jordan himself needs to
watch it once we go through everybody
and everybody's happy then we'll give
you the green light and they were like
at some point somebody is like nah this
is not good like we need to throw this
video away you need to be okay with that
and I was just like dude this is an
opportunity of a lifetime yes I was like
I will take all the risk don't worry
about it I want to come and do it we
went there as a team over two days we
shot it and in fact
I can't remember but I think we were
going to Europe right before a two we
shot that on like a couple hours of
sleep like we grinded that video
but now looking back it was all worth it
did they ask for any edits believe it or
not one or two changes they were really
happy with that so you're saying Michael
Jordan knows who you are yes he watched
your video yeah how's that feel is that
cool feels incredible uh I was telling
this to Mikey while we were over there I
was just so focused on the task I was
just kind of like nail this video out
you know do your best best job possible
then we shopped the video we were just
so exhausted and then once cameras were
off I was just walking the grounds I was
like oh my God like how did I end it up
here she's like I'm walking around
Michael Jordan's home
just like seeing the grounds and just
realizing that like in a small way we've
played part in history like this is one
of the most internationally recognized
individuals on the planet
and I grew up watching Michael Jordan
you know I used to be a basketball
player I used to play in Middle School
in high school and I was just like
it sometimes scares me because I
genuinely am so casual about this stuff
like in my mind it is all supposed to
work out this way like when we get
access to these individuals when I was
with Tommy I gotten nervous a little bit
but I was like this is so normal like
tell me being Tommy healthy Tommy being
Tommy Hilfiger I was like this is
calling Tommy yeah people are not going
to know yeah tomboy literally in the
video I asked him I was like would you
like me to call you Mr Hilfiger or Tommy
he was like Tommy
um so in some capacity I kind of forget
that this is reality and it feels so
normal to me but then I get these
moments I'm like dude this is Michael
Jordan you just spent 48 hours around
this property we got access to
everything and uh it's mind-blowing so
it's like these like weird highs and
weird like these calm Norms that I I go
through
um but I kind of like it I like a good
challenge I like a nice environment
change and I like a little pressure in
regards to like I'm a foreigner I still
can improve the way I talk I still can
learn more about the things we talk
about so I like that constant Challenge
and it's kind of rewarding to see that
Evolution like go look at our videos a
year ago I mean three or four years ago
and now they're so different what
surprised you the most about Michael
Jordan I think the property not selling
card friendly even to some aspect I
consider buying it because I think it's
had a great great price it's about 40 14
million dollars 14 million 14 million
it's a massive 40 000 square foot
compound so why do you think it hasn't
sold do you think there's a price where
it might make sense it's just a unique
offering okay it's not necessarily in
the heart of Chicago it's a little bit
out
it's a really big property and to some
aspects it needs a remodel but then you
kind of kill the character of the fact
that Michael Jordan lived there the
furniture inside of the house is worth
that much alone but the cat says you can
never take out the furniture and sell it
it either needs to stay in the home or
it needs to be like basically burned out
like you cannot Market the furniture you
cannot sell it so there's like weird
stipulations around the property why is
that I think it's just because the IP
Nike being involved oh I see they don't
want someone to leverage that you cannot
Airbnb the house you cannot have any
commercial uh interest within and so you
can't sell Michael Jordan's bed
basically that makes sense
um so all that coming together just
makes it a little bit of an interesting
offering where it may not be for
everyone but like I'm just shocked that
a celebrity didn't buy it yet and just
just so they can say I own Michael
Jordan's phone yeah but before we get
into that we just teleported to our
studio to discuss something incredibly
important in today's day and age and
that would be data privacy hey my name
is Jack Selby hi why are you putting my
name out there well your name and all
your information is online already so I
could just pretend to be you now oh you
know what's also cool I could open up
credit cards in your name you could open
up bank accounts even it's gonna be fun
sorry to break it to you Graham but I
have delete me see people like Graham
are exactly why you need to take
precautionary measures to remove move
all your data online and to be safe
delete me helps you protect your
personal data and keep it private they
specialize in removing your personal
information from data broker websites so
that you get a peace of mind knowing
that your sensitive Financial details
aren't floating around all over the
internet trust me guys there are
businesses that operate solely off of
the Commerce of private information you
really don't want to be on the other end
of that spectrum and you can't fathom
how bad it is until you're actually
experiencing a data breach like that so
check out delete me at join deleteme.com
ich20 to get 20 off all consumer plans
or you could just use the link in the
description with the promo code ich20
again that's 20 off and now with that
said let's get back to the podcast it
was interesting uh we I did a review of
50 cents house and I believe it was
originally listed more than 10 million
dollars the one in Connecticut yeah yeah
yeah
nobody and then I think it sold for like
three million three four million it was
something insane thousand square feet 40
000 square feet it was insane you know
who previously on that yeah uh Mike
Tyson so Mike Tyson sold it privately to
50 Cent and is like Pinnacle 50 Cent had
his whole crew living there with him
like the whole G-Unit area like they
were like literally deep people like
TV cribs and all that and uh we were
just at the cusp of being a big Channel
this is like that is one of those
opportunities I'm like ah I wish I'm a
big 50 Cent fan yeah so 50 Cent if
you're watching this video like I would
love to tour whatever house you have
yeah I'm just such a big 50 Cent fan
um it's one of those homes I'm like I
wish we got that I think they're
remodeling it right now yeah my
understanding needed a lot of work but
like at three and a half million bucks
imagine living in 50 cents that's I feel
like if I saw that now I would have
probably bought it yeah just for the
heck of it
um I have a question for you guys
you guys are both in the YouTube space
for such a long time Graham you're you
played a significant contribution for us
to even start a YouTube channel to begin
with yet along our success when you see
us featuring these kind of assets
Michael Jordan most expensive this that
how does it make you feel or like
what do you think about it all I'm super
excited about it I'm happy and I get to
now watch as you were and I get to see
like an inside look into these houses
through you guys so for me it's just
it's incredible to see it's cool to see
the come up because I feel like so so
many of us all like started around the
same time like have our journey together
from the from the beginning to now I
think is really neat Doug what do you
think I think it's really cool I love
watching your content because not only
do I get to see obviously like
incredible homes and everything like
that but I also get to like feel like
I'm also there because I know you and
Mikey very well though so it's it's it's
nice that I feel like oh I get to walk
through the most expensive Pet house
with my two buddies like that's kind of
cool I like how personal you guys are on
the camera as well like you're very like
friendly and you know back and forth and
you get to learn a lot about style yeah
I got to learn a lot about just showing
you yeah we've been having a lot of
discussions about style Ennis has
Immaculate style like everything that he
wears just blows me away so I appreciate
that was a nice talking point last night
I'm sure we'll discuss it at this
podcast yeah I mean it's like
at this point the the aspects of our
videos as a whole has gone really
difficult to improve right like I feel
like we're maximizing our DSLR cameras
at some point we probably need to up our
production gear to new set of cameras I
don't know what that looks like I know
Mikey is cooking fee ideas already in
his mind
um but then I look at it as like I'm
always a believer in constant Evolution
constant Improvement and to me I think
self-awareness is such an interesting
but a rewarding thing so to me as we
evolve the content as we gotten better
at what we do whether it's our
videography Shooters editors myself how
I present myself and uh how I carry
myself
and one of the aspects of that is that
as we eval as we increase the quality as
we showcase even better assets I feel
like I need to match up to them as well
and there's a fine line between matching
that level of luxury wearing a five
thousand dollar suit wearing an
expensive watch but then I still want to
retain that I am your friend I really
don't want you to be intimidated I want
you to be able to watch this video you
know at your house in your living room
comfortable and I think that's one of
the things that differentiate us no
matter how exclusive this content gets I
still want people to know that it's
innocent my key it's two friends there's
no need to be intimidated
please tag along with us feel
comfortable watch our videos and um it's
one of those things that I feel very
happy that like we broke which is this
need of being pretentious or like having
to live up to this like high imagery
because we represent luxury assets one
thing that I was so surprised to learn I
learned a little bit ago about you and
your business is the amount of an like
amazing byproducts unknown byproducts
that your business has so like obviously
you go get to spend a couple days with
Tommy Hilfiger right you go I'm not
going to name drop any other people
because it's it's not known publicly but
your phone book is insane you get to
spend time with billionaires all of the
time you get access like the highest
level of access without actually having
the like the wealth the money that all
the other people need in order to access
these things when did you realize that
this was going to be a possibility with
the channel so this is a very
interesting topic and I don't think a
lot of people know this but
the difference with us is let's say
you're a billionaire or celebrity and
we're going to tour your house
normally when you meet someone let's go
through the trajectory you would meet
them go for lunch dinner coffee you get
introduced to them maybe you hang out
with them a couple of times and then
maybe you get the chance to hang out
with them intimately at their own house
have a one-on-one moment with them well
think about my content right they're
like hey Ennis and the team are coming
they're going to shoot your house
I'm already in the bedrooms of these
people the fort bowl is already broken
has to be these people have to trust me
trust our team and they're kind of
letting us into their intimate space and
in a weird way I realize that that
immediately breaks the first few State
first few steps and we immediately get
to know each other very very closely
they have to within a few hours on the
property I already have their phone
number I already have their email
because we just set up a shoot where
we're going now and I think one of the
most valuable IPS we carry is the fact
that not only on a weekly basis we get
to see some of the most exclusive assets
on the planet when it comes to design
finishes level of service we also
intimately get to interact with the
people that are the consumers of these
services and assets
so that's giving us a wide range of
understanding of the luxury world that I
quite frankly challenged that even most
luxury concierge services and maybe the
even the people at this level that
operate may not know because the level
of frequency we get to do
I have billionaire friends and even
they're like Ennis
we don't even get to see horror of the
assets you get to see and like we're
actually the people who have the money
to buy them and our friends have them
but the level of frequency you get to
see them is just insane it's interesting
you call them assets and not properties
it's assets because it's Yachts RVs
motorhomes luxury travel anything and um
to me their assets and I find that world
very interesting I try to really spend
the time to understand it from these
people from these people's perspective
and I think that's also giving us a
Unique Edge when it comes to talking
about so what do you think you've
learned from all these billionaires I
think the fundamental thing that I
learned is the fact that
the way these individuals see these
assets and what they see what kind of
utility they see out of them are totally
different than public assumption and
totally different than what we assume
when we look at it uh we go oh the 40
million dollar yacht like why you need
it if you only use it for five six weeks
well what you don't know is
the six weeks they use the meetings the
interactions they have the guests they
invite they end up doing 500 worth of
business with them it's so worth it for
them to have a 40 million dollar yacht
so they end up doing 500 worth 500 500
what oh my God
that's a few times
yeah I know I heard it too did I make a
bit bad and sick or kind of like no I'm
guessing you you say uh trajectory
instead of trajectory yeah you said
projectory as well yeah wait so does
that mean 500 million dollars worth of
business yeah like the people who have
these like 40 million dollar yachts even
though they end up spending only six
weeks on their yacht when they the
people that they invite the the people
they do business with they might end up
doing 500 million dollars worth of
business with them because they're such
powerful individuals
um so it's not basically just like a
display of wealth be like see look at
you guys I I have this you know a
million dollar yacht or whatever 50
million it's not like trying to live the
life of luxury but a lot of the times it
actually has roots in the business
absolutely or like we have a friend of
ours who has a lot of cars and when I
was with him like a year ago he
showcased me inside of his garage with
like all these cars he goes and it's
I've never driven any one of these cars
I'm like then why you have him he goes
this is all for my friends when they
come in town as soon as any of our
business colleagues or like anyone that
we hang out with comes in town they get
one of these cars it's just like the way
they operate their business and it's
part of their like I guess imagery and
how they carry themselves so one thing I
asked Ryan sir hit when we had him on
our podcast because he's associated with
a ton of billionaires he's got like a
crazy phone book I'm sure of all of them
what makes them different than the
average person do they have like a
certain
I don't know style or traits or
different mannerisms than the average
person that you see on the street like
what differentiates them it's really
Case by case because
they can be so different from each other
but some of the commonalities I've seen
they're very Fearless like to them
making a 500 million dollar decision is
just the same as making a hundred
thousand dollar decision they're just so
Fearless
a lot of them are very focused like when
they work when they think about
something like they zone out they're
just in there they're shockingly calm
like sometimes I feel like I'm a little
too hectic because we just have so much
going on and we have such a dynamic
company and like so many things have to
fall into places for things to just work
out and then I look at them like I'm in
the room and I'm like even though I'm
there like I'm thinking about a bunch of
stuff
they're across from me they're just so
relaxed as if they don't have thousands
of employees and they don't have all
this stuff going on for them so um it
always shocks me how calm most of these
individuals are
and um
less is more they're just really focused
onto their business they they're just
like they have a great team and they
only work on few things and they do them
really well and that's what really makes
them successful do they seem happier
than the average person
50 50. some of them are kind of so
caught up in their lifestyle and who
they are I don't know if they're super
happy I don't think they're miserable
either
um some of them are very happy some of
them figured out
um
who they are and what really makes them
happy even though they have this wealth
and they have this image as byproduct of
their success they kind of know within
that system what makes them happy and
they just go do that
and the ones that are really happy are
the ones that can detach that high level
Persona and just be human and go like I
enjoy playing basketball I enjoy doing
these kind of vacations and I enjoy
being able to hang out with my friends
and get drunk every night and like don't
really care even the fact that I'm a
billionaire and they just go do that
those are the ones that I see are very
happy and I think it's deeply rooted
into their like self-awareness the fact
that they're very self-aware is what
allows them to be very happy I feel like
if I picture a billionaire at somebody
who's very like Stone Cold and focused
like you mentioned like I couldn't
imagine them like relaxing and like
letting loose and cracking jokes and
like oh I guess being like jovial in
certain ways or have you noticed that
they could be funny and stuff like that
like no like no sense for me it just
feels so detached it's hard to like to
see like to imagine just what it would
be like or what character traits they
would have I know what you mean and
there's definitely consistency
throughout there personality and how
they enjoy their time versus how they
work but I think the thing that I see
with them is like when they do something
they want to do it really well and they
want to really enjoy that moment so if
they're having a dinner with you like
they're having a dinner with you their
phones are off they don't really seem to
care about like messaging 20 other
people during the dinner or when they're
working they're working when they're
talking to their designer like they're
in there so I try to take that quality
and then apply to my life as well
whatever I'm doing I want to do really
good but I also don't want to overdo it
in a sense that like while I'm here on
the yacht I want to do things really
well but I really don't want to do that
extra work like if we're going to do
social media I want to do three things
and I want to do them really well and
that's it if we're going to do a walk
through I'm going to do it really well
and that's it like we have a Turkish
Channel
where we also do give or take the same
thing
this is a big trip and there are a lot
of variables we definitely have the time
to spin off a Turkish video I just
didn't feel like we could give the
attention and the quality where I would
be very stoked with the product I was
like no worries let's not do a Turkish
video it is totally fine I would really
do it really well then just do it and
kind of wing it you know now we gotta
have to get all the cabins reset back
again in order to master the quality
that I feel like would represent us
there's no need let everybody enjoy it
it's okay we'll do it on the next one
but we'll do it really well that's kind
of like what I see about them you just
want to really do the things and own the
moment what really interested me was
that the fact that the things that
impress billionaires are nothing like
the things that you would think would
impress them like you were saying that
they're not impressed by the most
expensive watch you were explaining that
you're considering buying a Richard Mill
which are you know infamously known as
like basically the most expensive
flights
yeah can they be in the millions too oh
yeah yes 100
it's like a samurai figure inside of the
watch it's like two and a half million
bucks right now it's insane I don't
understand it either okay but but you
were actually considering buying one
yeah right and this was because you
thought that it would impress the right
people or the people that you need to
impress to help out your business right
well like I think there's an important
balance
well at the at the level that we're
operating I think people look at us
meaning our team as the people not only
creating content but also individuals
who live this lifestyle to a certain
extent and be able to relate and
showcase it in a way that matches the
level of the asset right so they don't
look at us as just like oh these guys
know how to hold the camera and get
really pretty shots they also look at us
as well NS hangs out with these
billionaires he can relate to these
individuals he can create the video in a
way that YouTube audience can enjoy but
if a billionaire watches it they also
get their value out of it too so it's a
really fine balance right it it it's a
decent uh percentage affects how we
shoot the videos and how we narrate them
but to me if I'm gonna showcase these
assets I have to live this life to some
aspect that doesn't mean I have to own
20 cars and everything I I wear has to
be fancy but if I'm gonna wear a suit
Maybe it needs to match the level of the
asset so to some degree I position
myself and what I do on my weekly like
you know uh calendar who I hang out with
or what kind of dinners I go what I
educate myself on to this aspect of the
business and that also comes with appeal
as well so uh I have a friend of mine
who is a billionaire
um and I told him like I'm considering
buying a Richard Mill you know it would
kind of match our aesthetic and like it
would be a good addition to our Outlook
right I see myself as a representation
of the company so I want to make sure we
maximize that as well
and he said something very interesting
he's like
and this uh the people that will
recognize the fact that you were at
Richard Mille and being pressed by it
are kind of impressed by you already
meaning like more of the younger
generation uh the celebrities rappers
you know the more the people that wear
Richard Mill he goes I think you should
look at us
buying a watch that the sophisticated
and really like that one person audience
may look at and go you know what that's
not the most expensive watch but that's
a very curated watch only true what
enthusiasts would know and maybe
consider buying now watch I was like
that's a really interesting perspective
and uh
or I can get a custom suit made and
really spend the money on the fabric and
even a designer or a billionaire may
look and go
this guy's suit is like very tasteful
it's not the most show-offy or the
loudest suit but look at the fabric he
has chosen look at look at the fabric he
got used for his um shoot or like look
at his designer and how curated the
piece looks on him so I started paying
attention to these kind of things as
part of our Natural Evolution it's
interesting because the price difference
between a watch like that which is
obviously still extremely expensive how
much is that watch probably like 30 35
30 to 35 000 and a Richard Mill which
you could get for one two three million
dollars
that watch is going to impress a
billionaire most billionaires we could
say a lot more even though it's like
obviously a negligible price relative to
the price of the other watch that you
were potentially considering yeah
because like when you think about it
these individuals whether I have 10
million dollars 50 million dollars or
100 million dollars it really means
nothing to them and quite frankly
they're not going to be impressed with
my wealth they might be impressed with
my knowledge or your taste our taste our
team our operation how we carry
ourselves right so from that perspective
this is a not a most this is not the
most expensive watch but it's a very
tasteful and a simple watch it's to the
point uh it speaks their language a
little bit more than something that's
just expensive for being expensive
exactly and um
it takes a while to understand that
language
I'm still learning it uh as we go but I
started paying a little bit more
attention to that kind of aspect of the
business as well what are some of the
things that I've that billionaires enjoy
character-wise in other people like when
you go to them do you feel pressured to
act like extra enthusiastic or like
happy and smiley or like supportive
because I feel like they're always
surrounded by people that are probably
Yes Men but I'm guessing maybe you have
to provide a different perspective or
experience for them for them to like
enjoy yeah you know what I mean um it's
a case by case but
they always seem to be intrigued by
people's knowledge so if you're
knowledgeable if you can offer them a
perspective that they don't have on
something even if it's something totally
unrelated to their business or to their
Outlook
they seem to really enjoy that so A lot
of times I find myself talking about
design houses assets around the world
yachts
with billionaires just because they
don't have the amount of experience we
have seeing them so they always end up
asking really good questions or they're
intrigued with our business like
tell me about your YouTube channel tell
me about your team like how do you guys
gone to this point where like here you
are at my own asset you know my 50
million dollar home they're kind of
curious how a YouTube channel got to
this point uh
but again it's Case by case sometimes we
go and the owner is a little bit wild
they're like have some drinks have shots
we're like hey man we're trying to stay
sober for your video they're like no no
have fun enjoy you know just like right
before we shoot it's like plates of food
we're like hey we would like to just
keep things simple like we want to
really focus on the shoot it can get a
little bit carried away sometimes but
again it's Case by case and I think it
gives us a tremendous understanding uh
in regards to people that are Behind
These assets I think you decide at this
point what tour what not to tour like
what's worth your time at this point
like where do you want to spend your
energy believe it or not this is a part
that takes a lot of time for us because
you get 400 inquiries
we probably eliminate about
300 of them very easily it's just not at
the price point or level or they don't
have like that really unique interesting
factor for us to write it out
and after that our CEO Andy and our
operations manager Victoria they kind of
go through it they kind of filter it out
obviously we want to have a diverse
lineup of assets Yachts experiences
houses hotels whatever you name it
and then from there we look at it Case
by case does it fit into the schedule is
this something unique is this something
we haven't done uh like I'll give you a
little hint one of the videos we're
considering is
the most expensive rehab in the world
rehab for celebrities it will be an
interesting video we've never done
anything like this so we're considering
doing that or going to a different
country it all depends Case by case and
sometimes we look at a property we're
like this seems cool we'll do it we kind
of have the luxury and it kind of keeps
it fun you know so the agents at this
point just reach out to you and say hey
I got this new listing coming up yeah I
mean we we just get so many inquiries
where do you draw the line though
there's got to be like a threshold now
or it's like well we politely say we
can't do it we're booked quite frankly
we are I'm in between now we're in May
right now till September
maybe we have like eight slots available
the rest is kind of spoken for between
some of the properties they're Loosely
agreed right like hey we'll come over
there in August we may not have the
exact date but we know in August we're
going to shoot this home or shoot this
property whatever it is so like between
now and like September maybe eight maybe
10 new properties we can consider rest
is kind of spoken for
so I just go for like what kind of value
we can give to the audience and I try to
keep things interesting if anything what
I would ask you guys is like you guys
have seen the evolution of our content
what do you guys think with uh what do
you guys think in regards to the videos
we're choosing or like the ideas we're
pursuing
I think they're good but like you kind
of mentioned earlier you can't get more
expensive than the most expensive
Penthouse yeah so I think that shifting
the whole I guess the criteria of how
you would pick a video would probably be
a good idea to a little bit more of a
story a little bit more of a narration I
like this because or the Tommy Hilfiger
one as well because there's a whole
story it's not just because it's
expensive yeah but it's like the whole
back end of it I mean the Tommy Hilfiger
one you got to show you guys on jet skis
and stuff like that and there was kind
of like I would say like a beginning
middle and end I like that I think it's
nice yeah yeah I think history is a big
a factor that I think should be
considered like very historical
properties or things with um
so bad they what they just thumbnails so
bad yeah
celebrity celebrity properties would be
pretty good because then you can also
use their face in the thumbnail which I
feel like or had them talking about
their home with you I think would be
interesting yeah no definitely
celebrities
is an angle that we haven't really
explored it's also like between
sequencing the production team
scheduling and keeping a nice healthy
balance has been so difficult it's
probably the most difficult aspect of
our business
so I almost feel guilty of like ah like
if I work with a celebrity as you guys
know it's going to be a little bit of a
last minute right it may come with like
surprises where we may schedule the
whole thing relying on the fact that
we're going to get a one full day access
of this asset and they may easily come
back to us and be like well you have
three hours yeah which we can make it
work but then it ends up compromising
the content and that's where it's like
it kind of kills me like you right but
if it is better and it performs better
and it takes you to where you want to go
this is not worth it to make that risk
well that's that fine line of like leave
your passion aside make good business
decisions and that's the fine line that
I personally sometimes struggle I know
Mikey struggles too because like we're
so passionate about making it as good as
we can it bums us out as a team knowing
that like like hey we shot the video
like it's gonna be good but like we all
know it could have been so much better
and I I will also say I think that your
current audience would also be fine if
you were to maybe you know how like two
chains had the most expensivist yeah was
like his thing you could do stuff like
that too where you're not even touring
something like a yacht or a house or
something like that but you're doing an
experience that not a lot of people like
they know about but they don't get to
experience going into expensive I think
would be an incredible one that would be
amazing that would be incredible I mean
I have so many wild ideas as a team we
have so many wild ideas and that's
actually a good point so like one of the
things I feel like we're trying to
expand our brand is using social media a
little bit more because there are so
many cool things that we get invited to
just because it doesn't make it 20
minute long YouTube content it doesn't
mean they're not cool or interesting
that's why we really try to use social
media Instagram stories to be like for
example a RV company reached out they
make these like really really cool 200
000 RVs super techy really well well
extremely well built
they're just not big enough for me to
make a YouTube video but there's they
would be so cool if you go there get
like 10 12 stories one post and kind of
give people a little bit of an intimate
access that iPhone 101 experience of
like seeing it that's why we've been way
more active on our social media on our
Instagram
uh we're testing it out seems like
people like it I don't know if they're
seeing it that way but I'm I'm trying to
spread the variety of things we cover
whether it's a restaurant maybe but I'm
just trying to take it off from YouTube
because I just want our YouTube channels
to be very exclusive a restaurant would
be kind of cool even the Met Gala would
be cool like if you got invited to that
and you get to tour what it's actually
to set it up and to like the behind the
scenes and then just walking through
maybe you go like I don't know to the
water fountain and you see like Dwayne
the Rock like right next to you or
something that would be pretty cool that
would be pretty cool too I mean like I
think analyzing businesses is something
I always found very interesting like it
would for example touring like a big
Stadium during a soccer game and then
like analyzing how that business
operates what it takes to maintain a
stadium little things like that or like
touring an airport and with intricacies
and having the manager show us around
and like how many play in the planes
they land I think we have the capability
to do it right now we have a good thing
going on and it's kind of like
we don't want to disturb our
organization too much but as we get more
comfortable as we build the name to a
bigger point where we don't have to rely
on YouTube and YouTube viewership so
much and when I say YouTube viewership
I'm not saying that we don't want views
but maybe we're not so sensitive to how
many views we got right and then that
way we can really pursue these wild
ideas and do things that are even more
unique honestly touring a SpaceX rocket
oh yeah for sure insane I mean that
would be so cool like I I say it on
every podcast like I'm hoping that it
helps me manifest it but I really own it
toward the White House with the
president yeah like I really want to
you're telling me you think you have a
good chance to tour that I think so I do
think I have a good chance and uh I
think it's like it fits what this
country represents so much United States
is like all about opportunities anything
is possible I really believe in that
motto because it's like I lived it like
I came here when I was 17 years old
couldn't speak a word of English I don't
have a single friend and I don't come
from a wealthy family either and like
I've just cried in the I just grinded my
way out I've learned the language I've
really gave my focus and attention to
the culture I really wanted to
understand this country and its Essence
and I really appreciate that I really
enjoyed I'm really proud to call myself
an American and over the years just
being able to achieve one thing to
another that leading to another
opportunity and here I am having access
to some of the most successful
individuals some of the most expensive
assets in the country I genuinely
believe anything is possible as long as
you're honest you work hard and you mean
what you say life will reward you and I
really think at some point it's going to
lead us to the White House I can't wait
for that moment and quite frankly just
like I said earlier somehow it very
normal to me believe it or not I have no
hesitation that we're gonna do it like I
just know that it's going to happen and
it's not in any way being cocky it's
just like I just know one day before you
know one or two emails one or two phone
calls and boom we're in Washington yeah
I did some research into your team and I
got some questions that you're never
asked the juicy and I'm not gonna say
explicit okay but very interesting
details that you've never shared
publicly before I'm intrigued okay
so I heard that you used to have a car
flipping hustle okay yeah I did that
worked out all right
um I used to have a friend in Texas who
was a mechanic and um he used to work on
my cars
and then he would see me working on
houses doing other stuff he kind of
realized that I was a bit of an
entrepreneur he's like hey man I always
wanted to flip cars I was like what is
flipping cars he's like I'll go buy cars
off of Craigslist or like for sale by
owners do a few repairs get the things
right and sell us for a little profit
it's like would you be interested in
funding me and at that point he already
fixed some of my cards and I just really
like this guy so I was basically funding
him he would either fix the cars in his
backyard or in my backyard and uh we
flipped about like 10 15 cars profitable
we made money on every single one of
them are you serious why didn't you
continue doing it
I just like it gets a little messy you
have cars around for no reason uh
another funny story so I have it you
guys saw my production man yeah so my
dealer friend gave me an Access to an
online auction and there was this big
auction in Houston that they were
selling Enterprise then Fleet all these
Vans were like issues they were selling
it and I always wanted to buy one of
these four trans events and I got
introduced to this dealer through my
friend who was flipping the cars so I go
to Houston there are like seven of these
events and I'm kind of like I can buy
either one of the five like they're all
good to me low mileage so the first one
comes it's not the ideal one I want to
buy but it stopped at like fifty
thousand dollars or something I'm like
this is so cheap like this guy's gonna
buy for fifteen thousand I raise my hand
they're like sold
I was like okay well at least I secure
the van things are good second one comes
stalls at a ridiculous price
I'm looking around I'm like I cannot
believe this guy's gonna buy this
one-year-old van for like 12 Grand raise
my hand sold third one comes the third
or fourth one is the one that I really
want sold
I called buddy of mine who used to live
in Corpus Christi I'm like you have to
come to Houston ASAP he goes what'd you
do dude I bought three events I have
three events I only need one even at
that I made so much money just selling
the Vans I just got it fixed up I at
some point I had three High roof for
Trans advance and I ended up keeping the
one that I mean it's so cheap what
happened the ownership auctions that's
the move you got to go there if you want
to buy some affordable cars okay so what
do you think about car flipping as a
side hustle in general for the average
viewer do you think it's viable like it
is literally viable uh and I think there
are so many how to do videos on YouTube
now you can fix so many of these things
on your own with few tools and just like
um just even detailing a car fixing the
paint job a little bit like there's so
many of these like uh mobile uh
detailers you can get a bumper painted
for like 200 bucks so there are so many
ways to elevate a car uh it's kind of a
fun hustle it's like it's right up there
with like couch flipping and like
referring finishing and refurbishing
furniture and all that you've had a lot
of side hustles though you're you're
kind of a a grindy mentality person from
what I've figured out you also I I I
heard that you're a realtor at the same
time driving Uber yes
um when I moved to LA
you gotta understand my whole life I
worked ever since I've been 14 I've been
making my own money windsurfing
investing I've never stopped ever since
I'm 14 years old I've been making money
so I moved to LA and I basically
followed Graham's uh real estate course
he was just saying like he was preaching
uh doing rentals just so you can get
your foot off the door and just like
meet people and all that so
but at the beginning it just takes a
minute yeah I didn't know anyone in La
yes you hold open houses and like you
door knock it's just like the first few
months are kind of like slow and I just
couldn't contain myself I didn't know
what to do and I didn't I didn't want to
just go waste money just so I interact
with people in LA and I have an S-Class
I was like great I'll sign up for Uber
Lux I'll drive wealthy people around it
would be a fun way to learn the city
dude I was going everywhere with a GPS I
didn't know anything about it like
so at night I were doing Uber Lux and
funny enough I've done it for like a
month month and a half maybe I broke
even because I would drive for two weeks
and I would hit a pothole and it would
break one of my rims and I would have to
spend 1200 buying a new Rim but it was
just fun it gave me a perspective it
gave me a relatable point it made me
understand Uber in general so it's like
to me life is all about what you make
with what you have so even that I'm
appreciative like I've enjoyed it I made
no money I've never earned any clients
from it but I learned a lot about La did
you get close to getting any clients I
rented I think one property out of it
really uh that was about it though how
do you bring it up in conversation uh I
just feel it out some people don't want
to be bothered so they would just sit on
the back I'm like great you clearly
don't want to talk and I don't want to
bother you some people would be way more
Converse conversational and they would
just want to engage with you and I would
just build up the conversation and a lot
of people are interested why you do you
relax I'm like I'm not even a driver
this is like a side thing for me just
say I'm a real estate agent this is how
I meet clients and a lot of them
actually found that very fascinating
yeah and that was my two-month Uber
career wow I'm sure everybody asks so
how is the market yeah how was the
market what do you think of that yeah
classic I get that question so many
times I'm like we live in a different
world now it's so hard to predict the
market there are so many variables you
analyze everything then a war breaks out
yeah
how are you supposed to predict anything
yeah you just go along so I heard you
came up with this hack to make all of
your house flipping way more profitable
than everybody else what was that hack
so when I was in Texas building and
remodeling homes you got to understand
these are 100 to 400 000 homes so you
don't have a lot of wiggle room you have
to kind of copy paste follow a formula
do what's expected to turn around the
property that really bothered me I love
doing things efficiently effectively and
I love improving the things that I do
when I was in Texas building developing
remodeling homes uh
the price range was anywhere from
hundred thousand to four hundred
thousand dollars and at that price point
you can only do so much you're kind of
limited to how much you can change the
layout of the home and bring you know
quality finishes
and
as I knew how to do the copy paste and
the formula that worked I always looked
for ways improving it so I was like
great I want to use better materials
they're expensive so I have to find a
way to get them cheaper appliances best
thing you can do is go lows one day a
week to check out if they have dented
appliances a lot of times these dents
would be on the sides well if you place
the applies to where it needs to go you
don't see the Size Doesn't Matter so I
would give people a two thousand dollar
stove on 150 000 home every time we
would have Realtors looking at
properties they're like how can you put
this stove in this house it's like don't
worry about it I became friends with all
the employees appliances uh cabinets
that are broken on the side I would get
like a 36 inch cabinet I would have a
side damage well if you put it on a
corner you're not going to see the side
now you have a 600 cabinet that you buy
for fifty dollars because it's damaged
on the side and you give it to the
homeowner so I learned the frequency and
how lows would get um appliances
and basically the day or two after that
they will look at it all if they're
anything damaged they would immediately
put them up for sale on a lower price
point and they would have dates on the
bottom and depending on how long it sits
there
every two to three weeks I forgot the
frequency they would get the right to
Discount the price even more so I would
watch an appliance that's like four
thousand dollars and they would say now
it's discounted to 2500 and I'm like Ah
that's still too high I would just wait
for the week or that turnaround time and
I will show up there the next morning
I'm like you want to be the first person
to see exactly now I'm offering you 1500
they'd be like
spent three weeks yeah sure you'll just
scratch it up and give it to me for
fifteen hundred dollars
so my obsessiveness to improve every
little thing I do gone to that kind of
ridiculous level and like there are so
many hacks another thing I can tell
people let's say you're remodeling a
house go to Lowe's go set up a
commercial account
project what you're going to use in the
house pick the hardwood floors pick the
tile pick the fixtures pick everything
you're going to use in this house ahead
if you have
I don't want to say division but if you
have the capability to see a project
that far ahead interior door is
everything let's assume that you're
going to order forty thousand dollars
worth of finishes if you order them at
once number one they will deliver it to
you for free so you don't have to go
there one by one pick up all these
materials you would easily get anywhere
from 10 to 20 off just like that by
literally not even doing anything and
still buying the same material and you
can return them anytime so I've figured
it out every nook and cranny to save
money and now like that's why not only
my homes are very profitable
no one could have competed with me
almost every single home I flipped broke
the neighborhood record they still offer
that uh yeah I'm pretty sure I haven't
been at Lowe's in a while I did
something similar do you remember on the
the duplex my washer and dryer that I
bought from Lowe's yeah I got paid to
get a brand new washer and dryer I made
50 on this
I'm getting it for free I bought the
floor units and they were discounted and
then one of the units had a dent on the
side and so they gave it to me at a
really low price okay both of them were
were efficient so for the State of
California they offer a rebate back okay
I bought these I got the rebate back
when everything was said and done I made
fifty dollars buying these things so I
paid 50 to go and get a washer dryer now
that would not have been the case had I
not bought the floor unit with one of
them being damaged but the dent on the
side was only noticeable when you look
at it from the side so if you put
something you know next to it you don't
even see it it was so minor it didn't
affect anything but I got it for free
I made money I made money by doing that
so it's possible yeah the right
appliances that are there are so many
hacks understanding
understanding how a house is put
together and micro breaking it to points
where like
you'll hire a roofing contract there
thirty thousand dollar I'll fix the roof
for you great what is Roofing you need
to demo it you need to resheed your
house meaning you need to put a brand
new uh plywood then you need to actually
waterproof it and then you need to put
your finished material so it's a fourth
four-part job if you're individually
hire and you're the one managing it
thirty thousand dollar roof job goes
down to fifteen thousand dollars
so understanding these little things to
maximize the value I can give to people
who bought these houses it was like my
like motto of my business that's what I
did and that's why I no longer want to
do it because I'm like
I'm too much of a perfectionist to flip
homes
I should be building like 30 million
dollar homes so I can go like
all out making perfect and get that
premium otherwise it's not worth it you
were mentioning to me that there's a
billionaire out there can't say his name
that you consult with on him building
his house yes and that's a way that you
Foster this relationship and you've
improved it is the fact that like you
have seen so many hundreds of millions
of dollars homes or tens of millions of
dollar homes that now billionaires are
coming to you to ask what type of
appliances and like countertops they
should be getting in their house I met
with a billionaire who's designing a
house in New York and like his his
folder for inspiration was screenshots
from our videos
like that's what he showed his
Architects that are globally known they
were like I like this couch it would be
an episode I like this kitchen it would
be an episode screenshot he's like I
watch every episode and I'm like you're
a billionaire you don't have better
things to do they're like like you know
like we watch it every week with my wife
wow I'm like I wonder if you can go to
those billionaires that watch your
content and say if I were to not make
videos about House tours is there
anything else that you would like to see
because chances are if a billionaire can
carve out the time to watch something
because they're so excited to watch it
the average person probably you know
what that's a great question I should
ask that like what if they just say like
because I saw like a most expensivist
like two chains where he was like trying
like the most expensive water that's
ever existed or whatever something like
like a luxurious experience that they
can afford but it's just so crazy and
foreign that everybody wants to know
what it's like I feel like two chains
was going for that virality and like
almost like that comment engagement like
this is crazy that you pay two thousand
dollars for water he would almost find
these like absurdly expensive things uh
that's that's a great question actually
I'll start asking that that's a great
point one thing you always say is that
there is nobody that exists on this
planet that can catch up to you
how are you so far ahead and like and
why are you so far ahead what did you do
so I think it's a combination of a
couple of things number one
I'm very ambitious and very competitive
I think number two when I get involved
with something I just don't know how to
stop myself and I just go through
everything like I learn every aspect of
it and number three I always feel like
I'm about 10
not as good as I can be and I always try
to constantly chase that but to me it's
always ten percent missing I'll watch a
video I'm like I could have done this a
little bit better I think that keeps me
going and almost
gives me this Relentless energy and
nothing makes me more happy than seeing
a finished product or a work that I've
done
that looks really good that just makes
me Overlook all the difficulties of it
like it was the same thing with houses
it would have gotten at some point I
would get these big projects that are
profitable but I will take on doing a
lot of the work myself just because I
want to do a really good job and I want
to use that as a stepping stone
and I would spend like 16 18 hours on
construction sites just doing the work
and like running the guys and at the end
I'll look at the house I'd be like okay
I'm happy I forgot all the painful weeks
that led to building this house so
um
and I genuinely and I don't want this to
come off as bragging but I genuinely
don't know if someone can push it at a
level that I do and maintain decency and
like motivation so you think you're just
that much more competitive than
everybody else this was like this when I
was a winter for two everything like
we're a professional athlete which I
guess like you kind of have to be honest
level I won three World titles like the
the last two World titles I won I didn't
win them like there was no competition
like we would do 10 Rounds I would win
nine of them like to me if I won with
like a fierce competition like in my
mind I was like I would have been like
I'm not good enough like I won by
destroying my competition and later on I
lost that Competitive Edge I got injured
and I've done other stuff but like I
wasn't happy with it like to me if I win
it's like I have to win so far out that
people shouldn't match a competition
around me as that's almost maybe too
obsessive and like
in some capacity toxic yeah I just don't
know any other way we kind of had a
little bit of a debate last night versus
output or on output versus uh effort
true which is kind of interesting go for
it so my thing has always been to
increase the frequency of uploading to
maximize what you could do right now
because I feel like you know in many
ways you have such a unique opportunity
right now and it's up to you to really
maximize what you could do with it even
if that means posting a little bit more
you've been talking last night about
scaling back yeah it's a tough phone for
us because we're like 200 plus videos in
now at this point we've done so many
tours and I think at the beginning there
was a huge demand for like these tours
and we kept pushing the boundaries where
we set the standards so high for these
tours to go viral that I feel like it
had a bad side effect on the composition
they're not getting as much of used as
as they used to but at the same time
same uh applies to us now we really have
to make unique videos then I look at it
internally we have a team that I would
rather have them be happy and creative
than just working because things not
things have to get done and I realized
for us to be stimulated we need to make
better videos so on a personal almost uh
selfish way I'd rather do less videos
but better videos I think I would
personally get a more joy out of it I
know Mikey feels the same way
so on that level
basing our future on that personal
decision of our personalities then we
need to look at it and go well if you're
gonna make less videos how do we
maximize them
we erase the stakes we bring more
influencers we we give more depth to the
video we use the social media heavier
than we used to and while we have the
personality maybe we engage with events
consultations and other stuff more so I
kind of looked at it as like okay this
is what we want to do how we can make it
sustainable that's my way of looking at
it
um and I think there's no wrong-sided
argument because I think we can do what
you're saying it will be profitable
business maybe to some aspect it will be
less fulfilling but easier business to
run now we have so much of the stakes
right think about it you're building the
entire business or you're you're basing
the entire business off of 40 videos
that's so dangerous if five of them goes
bad now you're down to 35. they really
have to come through but I think that's
when the confidence and belief
and the team comes in and I have no
doubt like we're really good I really
believe that we really work hard
everybody on our team cares so much I
think we have a really unique production
team
that operates as a professional
production team but it's kind of a
family and it's a weird dynamic to have
in this kind of media space
but I think we can use that and we've
been using that to our advantage and um
I think as long as we make something
unique as long as we make something that
are hard for people to con replicate
there will always be a market for it and
I'm just I just believe in that and I
just commit to it I think that's what
really distinguishes you guys is the
ability to go 10 more to like basically
99.99 effort on every single video If
You scaled that back and increase the
upload frequency I think that it would
probably just blend you in with all of
the competition that you're trying so
hard to avoid
so I think that it makes sense to to
scale back but to really drive home the
the videos to make them as as good as
they can possibly be like I genuinely
believe we have the coolest job on Earth
it's up to us meaning as a team to
optimize our workflow optimize the way
we run our operation where we can really
enjoy that and feel that way on every
single shoot sometimes it gets really
hectic you guys know the drill like
you're out there you're grinding it out
making it happen late you know late at
night you're editing so my my heavy
focus is more on like how do we optimize
this how do we make this more
sustainable where we are doing our best
mentally but we're loving what we do and
it's a tough formula I mean it's easy
easier said than done yeah but that's
something like I'm heavily focused on
this year to make sure every experience
feels amazing every tour we do like
teaches us something new now I have a
question for you guys obviously reducing
the videos down
increasing the quality still takes quite
a bit of time but at the same time it
allows us to have more free time where
we can focus on other stuff there are a
few businesses that I'm considering uh
maybe we make some online courses on how
to be a YouTuber how to be a real estate
agent and showcase some of the best
agents on Earth because we have access
to them I really enjoy fashion and
clothing I'm considering partnering up
with some brands for them to produce
exclusive clothing for us because it
needs to live up to that level
there's another thought that maybe we
should get into Home Goods
Our Own Furniture that we maybe partner
up with the brand
if you guys were in our spot what would
you guys do what are some of the venues
that you guys would like I think if you
offer like an Airbnb or like you own a
yacht like this and you say this is my
yacht I'm renting it out you're gonna
get this luxury experience that we
curate for you guys like I think that
would do so well
interesting that's a really good idea
yeah I I personally think I have no idea
how product works especially with like
appliances but I think something
relating to really fancy homes like nice
appliances could probably work out
pretty well because I'm assuming a lot
of people watch your content to get
inspiration for what they want to build
in their own home and I know a lot of
the people that reach out to you wanting
to sponsor your content and like somehow
be affiliated with you are companies
that create those types of appliances
and stuff like that big sliding doors
and windows and stuff like that so I
think if they're reaching out to you
they probably know what they're doing
and they probably know that that can
convert pretty well so if you could
somehow partner with a company that's
already doing luxury appliances and
goods and stuff like that and create
your own line of it probably would be
pretty it's going to be tough because
you're thinking about like a homeowner's
not going to be going and saying I want
to replace my Sub-Zero refrigerator with
the new you know yeah but I think it's a
lot of people that are like looking at
what they want to build or what they
want to like people for future
projections people are so set and you
know if they're buying melee and they
want something that anybody from around
around the world they know Sub-Zero they
know melee they know certain appliances
you know I I don't I think an experience
that people could go to and I think that
would do the best I think I think
luggage travel suitcases that'd be
pretty good would also do really well if
you partnered with like to me or
something you know something like that
someone at that level yeah and you put
your spin on it but then it's only a
one-time sale and that's the thing and
good luggage is Gonna Last like decades
decades so that that's your problem
there but I think a good vacation
experience could tell their friends
about it they might come back every year
like a boat like this imagine you make a
hundred thousand dollars a week and you
talk about it it's like your cars and
bids.com is your you know your luxury
experience you plus Chargers whatever
yeah and you could you know do a yacht
like this but then you could also be so
easy to partner with a rental car
company that does luxury cars yeah
um you know maybe experiences where
people could go hand gliding or maybe
like a like a jet get a taste of like
what we get to experience exactly and
you could offer an affordable experience
per person
30 people want to you know go in on that
I think that would be fantastic well I
really appreciate that guys thank you
you have any other questions I I think
I'm I'm good I'm just really happy to
see you guys sitting in front of me in
Croatia right now it's kind of a bit
unreal but uh no I think that's all I
got I gotta thank you so much for making
this happen this has been such an
incredible experience seriously Mikey
come over here get over here show your
face of the camera I want you to wave to
the camera yeah wave to the camera shout
out to Mikey too if you guys have made
it this far please comment Mikey
basically created this entire shooting
uh structure here three cameras I even
brought the cheese plate yeah it's like
the cheese plate I mean he's going above
and beyond if you guys could see this
setup right here that's the nicest
camera I've probably ever seen in my
entire life yeah and they're just so
graciously letting us use all of their
equipment on this yacht that they've
also sourced I mean it's absolutely
amazing so I couldn't thank you too
enough it's my pleasure I wouldn't have
it any other way yeah thank you guys for
coming thank you shout out Mikey in the
comments thank you guys for making this
happen yeah we'll link to all of your
info in the description
Down Below in the description if you
guys want to check out this Yacht for
yourselves make sure to subscribe and
give it a like until next time thanks
yes